as coveted cases continue to rise in
southern nevada a las vegas man is
speaking out
on his experience battling the virus
christian joins us in studio with what
caused him
to share his story christian well
kirsten marcus cosio tells me kovitt has
been one of the worst things he's been
through
in his life today he's recovering and
also reflecting
on his decisions of not wearing a mask
and getting his vaccine
i remember just that feeling of
not being able to breathe 29 year old
marcus cosio is still fighting to
survive after getting covet 19
in july not one idea
you know i i work
and i maintained a lot of safety and
i respected distances and whatnot
but just through the slip of a crack
somewhere
it got to me the north las vegas father
of two tells me at the beginning
he did all he could to get better but
his health took a turn
and he was rushed to mountain view
hospital i got up
ran to the bathroom and i was
holding myself inside of the restroom
trying to use the bathroom coughing
i mean gasping for air and
at that one point right there i thought
that was
it today he is at home recovering and
reflecting on his decisions
that he says could have prevented this
nightmare beginning with mask wearing
and getting his vaccine
he hopes this will motivate others to
get their shot i was
never really against the vaccine
i wanted to just wait a little bit for
it
i should have gotten it sooner
if it meant that it would help me
that this much well marcus says he can't
get his covet 19 vaccine
until october until then he says he will
put the mask back on
and keep his distance christian casa
does 8 news now